hi everybody so it will be a bit more
than just yet but it doesn't matter
so I usually walk around a lot being an
Italian I just stick you late a lot so I
see the limited space here I'll try to
make it work so I'm Johanna and Danny as
a student said if you want to write life
or a batch smart snarky remark that's me
that's my Twitter handle down there my
wife always appreciated when somebody's
not does not agree with me because I
mean she's not the only one who I
imported yeah imported from Italy in
2006 by my wife before it was cool
moving outside of Italy I somehow got a
masterpiece in theoretical physics in
Leiden and after that I was a PowerPoint
monkey at KPMG as a software quality
consultant and then three years the data
Whisperer goodies are driven and down
since like a year I'm chief science
officer and senior shoe designer there
that means that if you come work for us
I'll design a pair of Nikes for you and
that's probably news already said we're
hiring
I wasn't sheriff Palais des Amsterdam
last year and now not anymore and the
reason it's in the last bullet point I'm
father of five that means I'm pretty
busy usually and I'm dick organiser they
Pilate I meet up with a lot of fine
folks here in the audience so what I'm
going to talk about oh I have like a
convention if you need to ask question
this is the hand sign you have to make I
usually try to stop so data scientists
in 2012 already so four and a half years
ago they wrote this article that kind of
went viral the sexiest job of the 21st
century and of course a lot of company
wanted to do data science from that
moment and
I don't know about you but a lot of
companies do data science they want to
do machine learning and of course the
first question is what is really machine
learning and in essence machine learning
is learning from data yeah so you have a
lot of data maybe not some so much and
you want to generalize so like the the
yellow points are the are the data
points you're getting and you want to
find the blue line and of course you
have lots of possible options and as you
can see here you could choose like the
blue line which is okay but it doesn't
really capture the richness of the of
the underlying data you could choose a
green line which is better or the red
line which seems I mean if you know a
bit on machine learning it's widely
overfitting and the thing is that a lot
of companies forget is that a hundred
percent correct answers might not exist
and maybe the hundred percent correct
answer is not what you want probably
many of you knows amazon.com and the
shopping experience that you have looked
like at the end of the page or somewhere
in the middle I don't know they say
other customers also bought this these
items and what some people do not know
is that Amazon is not using the best
algorithm that can use because people
were freaked out by how good Amazon
recommendations were so of course they a
be tested like they do with everything
and people really didn't like the better
algorithm they want something they want
something worse but that didn't scare
users so even though you can actually
get a green line here maybe you really
want the blue line and it has nothing to
do with science it's all to do with
business so a good peer or good product
owner needs to actually find the
that is the best trade-off between these
two tensions
now what machine Ernie can do of course
it can do everything supervised and
supervised reforms learning and the next
question is then what's data science and
of course for me go into a lot of
companies data science it's about
creating value using data and may use
machine learning may use visualization
visualization or analytics it can be
done with Excel or whatever you want but
it needs you
it needs to create value so if you have
just a batch for or a report on your
laptop or whatever and nobody is using
it even though it tells the truth
it's not really helpful and then of
course this is what we say and then when
you go to companies and you say data
science and they want to do data and
predictive modeling advanced analytics
that all the buzzword are they hear
about they want to make more money and
all the other things the others are
doing who these are there are they they
never know but there are others are
doing cool things with data science they
want to do that as well so how they try
together so first of all you need to go
beyond the data warehouse so usually in
the traditional data or bi word you
would have the traditional data
operational data sources in your company
and then it was the job of some DBA to
actually import them into the enterprise
data warehouse somebody would sit down
beyond laptop write a query and once you
write a query all the dependencies for
your for your query are contained in T
into the enterprise data warehouse so in
principle what you just wrote can
instantly go live and you can power your
traditional business app your web app
your dashboards reporting instantly
because everything is there but now
people want to do more and they want to
add structured data they want to add
logs chats transcripts they want to
scrape external website the
to use an API and of course CQ is very
boring so they want to use machine
learning and now they have this problem
of data pipelines because the first
thing you see here is that the typical
DBA and I don't want to offend anybody
but it cannot really build these
pipelines between all the new kind of
data that you want to use in your model
into this data platform and then you
need people to think about the
appropriate storage because not
everything can be contained secure and
then you want to scale so the promise of
all these new frameworks and everything
is that you can secure very cheaply
of course SAP and Oracle can also scale
if you have all the money in the world
but that's not what most company
companies have and this landscape
contains way more challenges that you
may think of because of this oldest new
tooling that you're using so a lot of
clients we have they use Park and why
they use Park even though they don't
have big data somebody wants to take a
gas because codes fancy the others do it
very good
well in principle they say if I use Park
even though I have little data now I
won't have to change my code when I
would get big so I have a simple
framework to rule them all so was a
couple of weeks ago was an energy
company here in the Netherlands and they
had this very cool spar pipeline to
basically determine the cut ball you can
imagine they were determining the
customer that I want that we're going to
churn and they're very happy they had
like nine months of work and then
somehow they found that the random
forest they were using was not very good
so from a level ten random forest
inspire they went to a level 15
and then the running time of the whole
pipeline shoot up by 11 by a factor of
10 so they were I don't know like they
needed 2 hours before and now they were
you meeting like 20 hours to finish the
pipeline and I said 20 hours it's too
much time we are not getting money out
of Eden yet but our Amazon bills were
just like they went through the roof but
the model was very good and basically
they had no idea how to fix it so they
looked at the code they looked at the
the spark UI and they were observing
very high garbage collection times and
what do you do when you see that you
have high garbage collector time in your
spark application stack overflow but
they couldn't find the answer into Stack
Overflow nor Google so they called us
and now I said please can you come and
take a look and of course I didn't know
the answer when I came in but I think I
can use Google better than okay that
they can but it's also that I know a bit
more of about Sparta they were that they
knew so it turns out that well of course
you have a random forest so when you go
to ten the depth of the trees go from 10
to 15 you get 2 to the fifth larger
models that means that they're models
that were that were serializing on on
disk and went from 30 megabytes to 250
megabytes on disk and they were trying
to make the thing faster by adding more
partitions because of course in sparta
say well more partitions is usually good
which is most of the time it's true but
and they just had like 4 or 5 executors
that'll remember pretty large executors
the thing is every partitions in spart
we load the model from disk every time
so if you have a thousand partition and
like three executors you will see that
each of those partition will start
reading the model from disk so they were
not only getting huge
garbage collection times they were
getting tossed this civilization time
what was ten times as that and of course
once you know it it's easy but to get
there it was a real challenge so a lot
of companies they know I'll seduce part
because I either read the book by Holden
or they read in a blog post and they can
immediately start doing things which
part and it seems like the same thing
after Python but then using another
framework but down there there are so
many challenges that are just waiting
for you to really use it with big data
and in real models to blow up in your
face
so what companies got a lot of proof of
concepts a lot of screenshots
presentations and dashboards that work
on your laptop with like 200 kilobytes
of data extra mouths to feed we know
really additional return because you've
got a whole department doing big data
now and then of course a lot of nice
stories to tell to their network to the
peers about those screenshots but
especially about the dashboards and then
of course all the data and
infrastructure is even more scary than
before because before I were just having
this operational data sources and the
enterprise data warehouse and now they
have like like new Satya spark and they
have a dupe and they have a class of the
zookeeper instances that you've been
sync and their vase and data qubit I
mean I don't even want to talk about
kubernetes which is a great thing but
when you're running it yourself there's
a lot of challenges and of course you've
got to talk to them we have the
scientists here working on trees and
forests and the neural networks and deep
learning and it can I follow the Twitter
feed of Pilate Amsterdam this today so
he you can they can tell cats and dogs
from each other that's it's great but
they actually just need a simple thing
which is they had to put things into
production and these things need to run
to generate value to generate money hey
they don't really teach that in any of
the use online massive online open
courses that are out there that I know
because they will give you extremely
good overview of how you theoretically
to data science maybe with a caption or
two but when it comes to I have this
piece of code and it needs an interface
to the rest of my production environment
that they start to well not it starts
not to be so easy anymore so what's the
typical process that you do in this case
so you start with the customer that has
some requirements and then usually you
start doing exploration and the modeling
and you need data sources and and what
you really need is that this models they
actually have to go into production so
the data scientists go to the data
engineer or to the engineer or to
whatever and it says I want to put this
into production and so the data engineer
or whoever asked ok where is the data
coming from oh I get it by mail every
Monday morning by this order Department
and it's very good the greatest data you
ever see and the engineer says well I
really cannot do that if you want to put
into production and I said well what
about I use bistec is it gonna help
I say well no it's not gonna help so
this is the first thing that breaks all
the data sources or the majority of data
sources are not getting in automatically
and that's like the majority of the case
we see are a problem of data sources
which are not coming in automatically so
I am doing a project at the Dutch
railways and they have a very cool model
to detect when a train with train brake
system is breaking down
and the data scientists were so happy
about it because one to two to three
weeks before a train would stop in the
middle of nowhere because the brakes
broke down they could detect that the
brakes needed maintenance so this is
like the perfect predictive maintenance
model and then of course you could ask
why are echoing us if they had this
great model now the thing is that they
needed two weeks between data being
produced by the train to data getting
into the model so the majority over this
train would break down anyway because
you didn't have the data in time on time
and the second problem is we write
crappy code as data scientist so I
remember a university when I was doing
my ID I remember it was a masterpiece D
my my supervisor came to me with with
the mathematical code I wrote and it
says don't you know that writing a
variable KKK is like bad form for for
this American Association that is also
named KKK and hurtling to the eye and
said well you have a very good point my
KK I was you nice or something I was
using it for something else and that was
true for X X X triple ax why all the
ladders were just taken and this crappy
code then you go to this data engineer
and I said I want to put into production
they look at you and say okay so where
are these commutations oh I know it
works I wrote a paper about it well but
where's the code documented no answers
and then they go there and say have you
written unit tests and you go actually
in what unit test like knowing that is
correct but papers being published
and then they say where's logging and I
said oh well I do a couple print
statement here and there and you see the
code is correct and basically that show
the code away and to write again from
scratch because it's such a huge amount
of work take something written sloppily
and then put it into production because
it's real so say once something is into
production you actually need to gather
the feedback that is coming from your
model and feed it back to their
requirement because maybe your model is
not working good
so always remember that almost
everything should be measured and
everything should be automated so this
this guy as a D at the Dutch railways
we're losing just for a single data
source 300 hours per year just to email
the data around that was going to feed
the model 300 hours per year for a
single source so how do we do that
building a data product so we start from
the backlog so we want to do something
and then we have to add data sources
because it starts from there from from
the input data we do feature engineering
and modeling or whatever and we got our
predictive model and from our predictive
model we want to productionize it and
here I wrote data product and smart
product because the first one would be
like an API and the second one would be
something that the you end user might
huge and it doesn't have to mean you
don't always need a smart product but
sometimes you do and then either your
data products and or your smart products
are monitored and measured so that you
can actually look how the model is doing
once you know how the model is doing you
actually can to get a new backlog and
then you can ask yourself do I need to
add a new data source they need to
improve the model I do have to extend
the API or watch
should I do here and this is also
something which seems very simple it's
just a stupid circle with some branches
but actually to do this and I slept a
little tonight to remember if I talk
about it in a in a sequence light but
actually what you need here is now if
you need a measure for your model you
need a measure and like in the Amazon
case sometimes accuracy is not the best
measure measure you can choose for the
Dutch railway case what should you
optimize for the times you take a train
out of the out of the system all the
time the thing breaks down because it
has a cost to take the train out of the
system but it's also I have a you also
have a cost when the train breaks down
in the middle of nowhere
and so maybe optimization of just the
accuracy is not the best one you need to
attach like an amount to each of your
false positive and false negatives and
you need a business case for you to
positive and true negatives so having
this metric it's deceptively simple and
of course in a psychic ler you can get
you have all this different sort of
metrics which are just ready for you
there but I see very little people that
actually build a custom metrics with the
cost of each miss forecast
another thing do is very important data
contracts where are this you have your
data products which you built in your
data platform and maybe your solved data
Lake and all different sort of data are
flowing from internal business units to
your data lake and maybe from external
data sources and then you go to this
guy's here org out there and you say you
should use our model it performs twenty
percent better
that the model that you're currently
using which maybe runs in your sickle
database and it's just query with a
couple of means and variances thrown up
in there and said this is very nice how
fresh is the data that you have here and
you say well we'll build this
spectacular data pipelines we get data
which is maximum of two minutes old and
I said okay well it seems very good
let's start using it then these guys
over here which are not using your
product but they're feeding data to your
to your data platform they decide to do
maintenance of the data base for three
days you don't get any new data so
actually the promise you made to this
business unit here was actually false
because we are not yet used to think
about SLA and I mean not everybody to
think about SLA and contracts between
the guys you're pulling data from and
the guys you're offering products you
and if you don't have that in place
people actually will never never use
your model because even though it's 20%
better if it's out for a week there
maybe they're losing millions so that
means that your data pipelines your data
contracts your data whatever should be
pro-grade when you build a data product
even though machine learning is maybe
dee-dee-dee hearth the data is the are
the legs of your data products
so what skills are they needed from a
from a data scientist perspective what
skills are needed so this I I took from
from a discussion on on the hacker news
a couple of months ago and is by no by
no way it's like a scientific proof that
it is true but I think it resonates
really a lot with the clients that we
have so here in this article they law in
the comments actually in the comments of
in Akron news they claimed that there
are two groups of people the one that
have work experience building data
products and strong software development
skills
and those without and the first group is
in higher demand than ever and I'm sure
I mean we are but I'm sure almost all
the sponsors are here to today they are
really really interest in this first
group if you have experience and if you
have software development skills you are
in higher demand than ever so the actual
reason that I changed my job title a
couple years ago to shoot designer is
that people wouldn't call me any more on
LinkedIn and it actually worked until a
lady from China asked me if I could
design some shoes for the factory there
luckily i i i I became chief science
officer arrived after that but anyway
that's it's it's really it's really a
thing and I think everybody here that is
a data scientist at some company that
you get cold at least once a month or
email or whatever if you're on LinkedIn
on average in the second group on the
other hand is extremely crowded because
everybody can ride on their CV they
followed and view ng course on Coursera
or somebody else whatever it's very easy
to ride that and I said well I got a
certification blah blah blah blah blah I
never checked that I don't know how many
people actually do check that but it's
extremely easy to just say well I
followed the Porsche and I'm a data
scientist now and so that means that
supply of the second group keeps growing
while the demand
it's either flat or shrinking especially
by executive getting burned by this
so-called data scientists that are not
able to participate in a work flow in
which things end up in production and so
this also actually the biggest
differentiator we're seeing is that are
you either I mean are you participating
in building production quality systems
and this is not building production
coding system of course because you I
don't think anybody expects from a data
scientist to build a framework that
Neal's presented in a previous talk but
you have to participate to that to be
able to give code maybe it's not the
perfect code but it's easy for somebody
to get in and treat the performance a
bit or change something without being
scared that everything will break down
versus being proficient in our Python to
hack to get our prototype on your laptop
with a small data set and I'm seeing the
same things happening here we as good as
a dream we're definitely all the
interest in the
in the profiles of the first group and
many if not all of our clients are in
same position yes and will be probably a
non politically correct answer your
question but I think two things the
first is that you have a lot of
companies like the older tech companies
interns first companies heavy R&D
companies that they have a very strict
hiring process for every position for
every technical position in their in
their department and a lot of other
companies they either hire to just look
at it at the CV talking to you a couple
of times but they do not have like a
technical steps in their interview
process to filter out resources to
things so there are many companies when
you just end up into HR let me speaking
to somebody from HR sorry and of course
it's very difficult for them to access
the technical skills that you need these
on one side and on the other side they
many people they still have to realize
that this is what is needed to actually
bring something into production because
if you come from a business intelligence
mindset you need to write some CEO and
then as I show you before the enterprise
data warehouse actually takes care of
everything or the DBA takes care of all
the data being there and you're
basically just writing some CEO which
could be optimized but still is just CEO
you're not expected to write test
documentation that sort of stuff they're
they have you have a much smaller
surface where things could go wrong
I think
does that answer your question okay the
P&L so the good news is that you can
learn I mean if you learn machine
learning and you know algebra you know
probability statistics you can also
learn to code I mean not code on a
software engineering level but you could
code enough to be proficient and to be
to actually contribute to to this
production system and I speak from
experience for somebody that were
writing everything as KKK and then
actually can write I can even write
tests now and of course you ask Neil
some Phillip turbo coder but it's you
can learn that actually are you get a
first position I think especially the
larger companies they have they have
much more space to actually give tracks
in which they teach people this thing so
you can start from a Virginia position
we work at several bank banks and they
have this traction which have like these
juniors people they come in they know
that their junior and they actually so
they're actually mentored by somebody or
they work in the team where you actually
can learn this stuff the problem is if
your whole team is composed of the
genius people then it becomes very
difficult for the company itself so if
you don't have this like supervision by
somebody that knows what it's doing
it's
it's more difficult but I don't have a
definitive answer on how you could fix
that so as I just was saying you need to
write good software that's that's just
as easy as this writing good software
already goes a long way into bringing
something which is a model that runs on
your laptop to put it into production
because the good thing is is that data
engineers do access and they can
actually help you with that
if you didn't write a piece of junk and
of course now it comes 'hey i've told
you so part because a couple of nylon
maybe six months ago i've wrote that a
lot of data scientists approach the
problem with a catalog mentality
delivering the best model in absolute
terms so this was tied to what i said
before that you sometimes need to
optimize for something which is not
accuracy which is not the standard
metric the scikit-learn the leadership
and I named that the Kegel curve even
though it's not written here because
cargo I think really encourages
encourages you to deliver the best model
in absolute terms without thinking of
practicality while in in general it's a
model that combines practicality and
accuracy or whatever other other metric
you have that gets implemented as an
example the Netflix competition ten
years ago next gave this 10 million 1
million euros dollars price so the teen
would increase the accuracy of the
recommendation by 10 percent I think
they were pretty high up that time maybe
80 85 percent and they want a model for
90 95 percent accuracy and this team
came out they I think they invented
metrics authorization
at the time to actually so this
particular problem and they want the
price and Netflix never implemented that
because it was too slow for the volume
of users and title that they had to
actually be using the production yeah
yeah and now of course nine years went
by and machines are cheaper and you know
a lot of things happened spark as well
since back since 2008 that makes this
much more feasible so now using a
medicalization problem algorithm it's
not coming it's less taxing than it was
back then by year you're right and I
think this was a last slide